Speaker 1: I have an update today to start with
about an investigation that many of you have been
asking about going all the way back to at least
March of 2021, although maybe further, I remember
certainly talking about it in March of 2021.
We've known that Republican Congressman Matt
Gaetz has been under investigation for a number
of different possible crimes, including sex
trafficking of underage girls, and he lawyered up
with some of the best sex crime defense attorneys
in the in the country. Quite frankly, we've been
expecting crimes to be charged at some point and
then nothing has happened, and many of you have
written to me and said, David, what's going on
now? Of course, I know nothing other than what is
reported. But we have a new report from the middle
of this week that Matt Gaetz ex-girlfriend,
has testified to a grand jury in the sex
trafficking probe, suggesting that by all
measures, we are getting closer to actual charges
against Matt Gaetz. No guarantee, but listen
to this report from NBC Congressman Matt Gaetz,
ex-girlfriend testified Wednesday before a federal
grand jury investigating him for sex crimes,
a major development that suggests the DOJ may be
moving closer to indicting him. The ex-girlfriend,
whose name is being withheld to respect their
privacy, has been in talks for months with
prosecutors about an immunity deal. Can you
imagine his ex-girlfriend may be liable for
criminality and wants immunity under a possible
deal? She would avoid prosecution for obstruction
of justice in return for testifying in the
investigation into whether Gates in 2017 had sex
with a 17 year old female for money, and whether
months later he and others violated a federal law
prohibiting people from transporting others
across state lines to engage in prostitution.
Legal sources familiar with the case say Gates
is being investigated for three distinct crimes.
Sex trafficking the 17 year old violating the Mann
Act, which prohibits taking women across state
lines for prostitution and obstructing police
obstructing justice. Importantly, Gates has not
been charged with a crime. Gates has denied all
accusations, saying he never paid for sex. He
never had sex with a minor when he was an adult.
He has called the investigation a witch hunt.
The attorney for Gates ex-girlfriend Tim
Jansen, declined to comment about the case
when he was spotted by a reporter entering
a courthouse in Orlando with the client. A
Department of Justice spokesman declined comment.
Gates did not respond to a request for comment.
The investigation has lasted more than a year.
It started when a former friend and ally of Gates
tax collector Joel Greenberg, was charged with a
host of crimes from falsely smearing a political
rival as being a pedophile or pedophile to change
to cheating taxpayers in a cryptocurrency scheme
to sex trafficking. The same 17 year old girl
and Gates investigation. Greenberg has agreed
to plead guilty and is cooperating with federal
investigators. An important aspect of the article
here is the serious nature of all of the things
Matt Gaetz is being investigated for. Now,
we don't know what's going to happen here. This
might lead to nothing. It's clearly not over,
and it is Matt Gaetz own
ex-girlfriend who ultimately
might provide the testimony or might provide
part of the testimony. We just don't know yet.
That leads to very serious charges against Matt
Gaetz. Now what about removing Matt Gaetz from the
House of Representatives if he is charged? You can
find a number of different commentaries on this.
It is typical that if members of the House
are charged with felonies that they resign,
they could be forced out. Although whether the
Republican Party would be interested in doing
that, particularly if they take over the House
of Representatives before charges are brought.
If they are, there's a lot of questions here,
but very, very serious charges. It's not over.
Will he eventually be charged? We just don't know.
But we could be just weeks away, and I know we've
been saying that for a while. We could be weeks
away from finding out the answer to that question